I've been a police officer road.
Some long questions for Echo Charles Reed.
He's been studying them for four hours.
I've been a police officer for about four years.
I consider myself to be proactive and try to get after it every day.
Much like many of my brother and sister law enforcement officers recently I
switched to a bigger agency with a,
with a bit of a different mission.
I still try to be as proactive and as thorough as I can in everything that I do,
but I've noticed that many of the front line supervisors in this agency want
officers to be reactive rather than proactive.
The supervisor in particular has told me to stop working so hard and get it
salty,
suggesting that I lower my morale.
The question is how do I build a relationship with these supervisors while still
being proactive and working hard?
So this is what I did when I got to seal team one.
I was this guy right here.
I was fired up.
I was,
hey,
oh,
we're doing the obstacle course today.
Cool.
I'm going to wear my rucksack with a 40 pound sand bag in it.
And all the guys that were older,
well,
you know,
looking at me like,
dude,
pump breaks
and you know,
of course,
what did I think those cards are hardcore guys are weak.
That's what I was thinking.
And then,
you know,
I thought to myself,
okay,
how can I,
how can I have influence over them?
How can I have influence over the platoon that a man can?
I have influence over the platoon that I'm in if everyone that's in my platoon
doesn't like me?
No.
Can you,
if everyone in my platoon doesn't like me because I am super hardcore,
then are they gonna steer it all in my direction?
No.
The answer's no.
In fact,
they're going to isolate me.
I'm going to have no influence over my platoon and that's,
that's a horrible thing.
So what did I do?
Did I just go,
okay,
cool,
I'll do it.
Looks like donuts is the deal.
No,
I didn't do that at all.
But I conformed.
But I conformed and people think,
oh,
that's weak.
You shouldn't conform.
Look,
you are not the priority.
You as an individual are not the priority in a seal platoon,
you're not.
The priority is the platoon.
The priority is the mission and if we're going to execute a mission,
we need to be very tight as a team.
So if I put my personality above the unity of the team,
I'm hurting our capability of accomplishing the mission,
especially if I realized that guys need to train a little bit harder and instead
of actually doing something that's going to move them in that direction,
they reject me and now I'm outside the,
the Brotherhood,
the circle,
and now I haven't moved them into the right direction at all.
So now there's one guy that's in really good shape,
me and everyone else is going in the other direction and I have no influence
over them that that's just terrible.
The mission is the most important thing.
In order to most effectively execute the mission,
we have to have the best possible team in order to have the best possible team.
We have to have trust and relationships inside the team.
If I
violate that,
I'm taking away from the team.
I'm taken away from our mission capability.
Now,
of course,
if there's someone that's grossly out of shape or out a standards,
yeah,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna try and tighten that person up.
But again,
if someone's completely out of standards and all I do is attack them,
what's their reaction?
It's too to step away from me to reject me.
But if I,
if I say,
hey man,
you know,
I know you've got a lot of experience and you know,
I'm,
I'm 19 and I just got a bud so I'm in pretty good shape,
but like,
can,
can you teach me some of the tactics that,
you know,
and all of a sudden I'm building a relationship with them
and then I say,
Hey,
do you want to go for a little,
a little John with me after work?
And you know,
that guy's done eight deployments and he's tired and he's old,
but he wants to be back in shape because we all want to be in shape.
And he goes,
okay,
short one
and we're moving in the right direction.
So that's what you need to do.
You have to,
you have to back off a little bit.
You have to find balance and you have to focus on the team and it's better to
have the whole team.
It's better to have 20 people that move a little bit in the right direction.
Then have one person by themselves that's going in the right direction and
everyone else is going in the wrong direction.
So that's what you need to do.
Take the sandbag out of your ruck sack a little bit and you know,
I ran with jungle boots on,
I did all this stuff and it didn't take me very long to realize I was not doing
the right thing,
not making my team stronger.
I was isolating myself and stopped it.
So this guy,
he should like what?
Start acting just a little bit salty or you nor you know,
lower his morale appearance a little bit to kind of fit in so to speak.
Yeah.
Do you want to be part of the team?
If you're not part of the team,
you don't have any influence.
If you don't have any influence,
you can't move the team in the right direction.
If you can't move the team in the right direction,
the team is less mission capable.
That's what you're there for,
is to make the team more mission capable.
Every moment that you don't do that,
you're,
you're doing something wrong.
So yes,
you don't have to show up.
I mean,
just imagine I was a new guy at seal team one people we show up to run the
[inaudible] course,
the o courses,
obstacle courses are really hard obstacle course.
And I show up with a rock sack on with a 40 pound sandbag it as a new guy.
Yeah.
You know,
of course got people like,
oh,
that's fired up.
But people were like,
okay,
Oh,
you're,
oh,
you're 19 years old and you just got out of buds and whatever makes sense.
We don't like you.
So
it's kind of like steering like a big Van,
right?
You can't just start making big turns with the big,
otherwise the thing's gonna gonna tip over a little bit.
See what I'm saying?
No,
you gotta like you can't,
if you gotta you gotta go slow is what I'm saying.
Okay.
You guys understand.